[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app
[Music]
congratulations studio and we've got
some dates we've got a plug here we've
got October 12th Santa Barbara coming up
in Riverside California and San Diego
California October 18th and October 19th
we've got about three or four shows
there San Diego can't get enough of the
Daliya
weekend Foxwoods Connecticut Bethlehem
Pennsylvania for some reason two shows
Rochester New York Royal Oak Michigan
Detroit Michigan we've got two shows
over there and New Buffalo Michigan a
lot of places in Michigan for some
reason Minneapolis Minnesota November
9th two shows filming is special for
Netflix Chris D'Elia and we have some
shows in Tampa Florida in November and
Melbourne Florida for some reason in
Hollywood Florida even though there's a
Hollywood California they decided to
name it Hollywood California as well El
Paso Texas for some reason Houston in
then Chicago Illinois just added another
date uh New Year's Eve overwhelming the
van that's 13,000 tickets lilia sold in
Chicago should have played in arena
didn't know it was going to be that
bonkers when he went on sale but it's
all good
Gator tickets out Chris ladakh album www
Chris little cow but anyway dude yeah do
it I'm back um and it's [ __ ] ripping
I'm back from Atlantic City and
so it's quick I'm back from Atlantic
City I shot some of army of the Dead in
Atlantic City I couldn't wait to get out
of Albuquerque and get to Atlantic City
couldn't believe I was saying I can't
wait to get to Atlantic City got to
Atlantic City Atlantic City and was
super depressed because Atlantic City
super depress all good I stayed at a
hotel that lost their gaming license so
there's no casino in the hotel that we
were staying in so I'm done with that
I'm done with army of the Dead I got one
more shoot day I have to do in
Albuquerque so it's all good kind of
drama knows out real good and plenty
when I get there gonna get there and my
[ __ ] lips just go like this and break
and bleed and all good and when you go
to the bathroom literally it's very
painful so it's all good so um well I
got back from Atlantic City Atlantic
City's crazy man I'm doing a zombie
movie okay so I'm dealing with like a
bunch of zombies when I'm I'm on on set
just going for some reason that's the
zombie noise for all of the zombie shows
and for Walking Dead you know I [ __ ] you
not dude I walk outside on the boardwalk
in Atlantic City and I see this homeless
guy and for real he's going like this
and I was like a zombies in real life
but yeah dude it's crazy about the about
Atlantic City and how it's a thing rooms
are like $50 a night so yeah and but it
was cool to be in Atlantic City for
extended period of time I guess I mean I
was in I've only played like The Borgata
and Harrah's and I go the day of and I
leave the next day because why would I
stay in Atlantic City about dude when
you're in the Borgata and when you're in
the like there's a hotel called Ocean if
you Oh totally you go in you might as
well be in Vegas do it except for the
people look like trees they're just not
as good-looking as the people in Vegas
know Vegas has the
I know make no mistake if there's slot
machines around there is troglodytes
around now if you were my opener you'd
say what's a troglodyte
well the troglodyte is somebody's a
troll it's basically a troll that lives
under a [ __ ] bridge or something like
that anyway it's a dumb [ __ ] word
you know what I mean troglodyte like
just make it shorter call it a Trog or a
troll but they don't the English
language likes to get [ __ ] jiggy with
it so they're having a dream with it
dude I'm wearing my future so bright way
too bright shirt because mmm future some
way too bright got me with the [ __ ]
shades on over here and you could see
the back if you were behind me but you
can't right now it's all good I'm not
gonna show it to you because I'm [ __ ]
don't want to and that's respect dude
that's [ __ ] straight-up respect I
mean not doing what I wanted me doing
exactly what I want to do for you guys
you're welcome anyway dude I am back and
I was in every Friday I went I went to
New York City because it was because I
didn't want to be in Atlantic City for
like two days off because I would have
[ __ ] you know it's crazy weird to be
like annika in a casino but also near
the beach
that's a jersey and seagulls even the
seagulls are like what the [ __ ] is going
on around here why are there casinos
squawk and so uh you see him if you look
close to their face or like squawk why
are their troglodytes squawk squawk this
was ours a little while ago squawk did
squawk so I went to New York City man
every time you go to New York you see
the most New York [ __ ] it's unreal it's
just unreal I was in New York and I saw
two dudes [ __ ] straight-up fighting
with each other arguing like not
physically fighting but they were like
it was like the next step was the
one of the guys has to like duck because
the other guy's gonna punch and they
were arguing each with to each other
about arguing with each other about
whose team was better suggestin New York
they were talking about the Giants and
the Jets so you're [ __ ] he said [ __ ]
your team you ain't [ __ ] your team a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but like for real angry um
and they were like you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
you ain't [ __ ] he was like you ain't
[ __ ] your teammate [ __ ] and you ain't
[ __ ]
he was like he was and the other guy was
a [ __ ] I'm gangster and he was
like you ain't gangster you ain't [ __ ]
without your boys like that's the what
was going on and they kept on like
walking away but then walking close to
each other now this was the most New
York [ __ ] not yet but this was the most
New York [ __ ] they were doing that to
each other and I [ __ ] you not dude they
were actually free langree up with each
other but they were all so [ __ ]
dapping each other and high-fiving each
other your friends are not I I'm not
bullshitting you dude they were like you
[ __ ] you ain't [ __ ] without your
boys you ain't gangster I'm mother [ __ ]
I am gangsta [ __ ] I'll kill you
[ __ ]
and they were like hell [ __ ]
[ __ ] your [ __ ] ass [ __ ] but I
respect that but [ __ ] you but they
literally said they respect that but
we're doing that and they were yelling
at the top of their lungs lungs
everybody was watching and they were
gonna [ __ ] shoot each other but they
were dabbing why were they doing it
don't know but that's the New York way
in a New York minute
oh everything can change in the New York
minute my mom when I was younger would
do [ __ ] would say New York minute and
but she would do it not the singing way
she would be like hey in a New York
minute in a New York minute and it would
always make me mad because in New York
minute is 60 seconds and that's how much
a regular minute is but she thought she
was crafty and cool and poetic now
that's what she does and it's all good
my babies moms are dramatic if your mom
made dramatic guess what she's your dad
because moms are dramatic as women get
older and especially if they pop kids
out when they become a mom they get
dramatic when my mom saw Columbine she
dropped when she saw Columbine on the
news she
dropped her notebook who the [ __ ] drops
stuff in real life for real who'd who
for real goes and then drop something
Keyser söze at the end she dropped a
notebook on my foot I go ow mom what the
[ __ ] it she's oh shut the [ __ ] up dude
[Music]
she said shut the [ __ ] up you know a mom
oh shut the [ __ ] up crap my Matt Matt
Chris um so yeah so in a [ __ ] in New
York minutes you drop the notebook on my
[ __ ] foot and it's all good now can I
get the cowlick down on the back of my
head now and it's all good does it piss
me off yeah it isn't gonna change it no
it doesn't matter but I need to look
good
no it doesn't matter but so anyway I did
she did she dropped the notebook and
that was when I realize when I came up
with the thing I was like wow dude moms
are dramatic but dads aren't you know
the heads aren't that's just [ __ ] a
little laugh at off and they get maybe
my dad sentimentalist [ __ ] too though my
dad all like that like if it's just and
I but that's my way I'm sentimental man
like when I see [ __ ] like involving like
a kid and and and a dad if it's a don't
give a [ __ ] if it's a it could be a
[ __ ] trivago commercial I'm crying
immediately if he was like I go to
trivago to get all my hotel deals
because I because when I'm staying with
my son uini and I'm just [ __ ] that
guy from trivago the commercial that
guy's handsome you know for sure he's
got no kids because he just stays
[ __ ] the trivago guys the [ __ ] went
out went out I wanted when I get older I
want to be the trivago guy no I don't
want to actually work for trivago but I
want to [ __ ] be that like that guys
so so handsome it's hilarious if you
have all even gray hair you're the [ __ ]
unless it's white then you don't look
good and that's the rules and I don't
make the [ __ ] rules dude the rules
are the rules that I figure them out
um anyway um but that's yeah so I saw
that New York thing and it was [ __ ]
insane and I was in Atlantic City and I
when I was in Atlantic City I was with
my buddy Garrett dillahunt and dude we
were like let's go out for the day [ __ ]
it we got we got wrapped like we wrapped
the day or today it was like 10:00 a.m.
woke up at [ __ ] Oh dark thirty and we
wrapped at 10:00 a.m. and then we went
to the [ __ ] factory stores dude have
you ever been to a factory store a
factory outlet bro they had Adidas
Reebok Nike Garrett likes a [ __ ] pro
bass fishing shop whatever the whatever
so we went there of course he does dude
my buddy Garrett gets those [ __ ] hats
that wrap all the way around the brim is
all the way around and it's not a cowboy
hat if you ever had by the way cowboy
hats get out of here if you're a real
cowboy fine but if you're just like some
chick that's filling herself on
Instagram take it off and if you're a
dude like this guy my buddy he get I
mean do it how annoying is it having the
[ __ ] thing over your face what are
you a [ __ ] member the wu-tang clan
fisheye man and yo yo what up is Fisher
man so he's got so he's got the if you
have a brim the brim stops here dude it
stops here you have a little plank
that's it you have a [ __ ] plank it's a
ball cap if you have the brim that goes
all the way around you better [ __ ] and
put some chips on it and some guacamole
on the top and take it off and start
dipping dude now that's a [ __ ] Grand
Slam and I don't even mean two of those
shits just come out I would love to see
a guy in a hat like that for real like a
fly for what what the [ __ ] kind of hats
are those anyway bucket hats or whatever
not a bucket hat but I mean buck hat - I
would love one day when I'm [ __ ] 70 I
want to get to the point where I just do
[ __ ] like this where I see a guy wearing
that hat and I walk in I get a bag of
chips and I get some guacamole and I
start putting the guacamole on the top
of his [ __ ] head and he says yo what
the [ __ ] you doing and I said oh dude
I'm sorry oh my god my bad I'm sorry
you're wearing one of those hats and he
says well why the [ __ ] you put in
guacamole on it and I say well because
the
the only reason some shaped like that
would exist would be if you put dip in
the middle of it and chips around the
brim and then I'm ready to fight and if
I lose I lose but you fight for a reason
dude I'm Jon Snow in this [ __ ]
if I see a brim that wraps all the way
around and I'm 70 I'm getting chips and
guacamole and I'm Jon Snow because I'm
fighting for a reason dude these are the
real shits
and the guy beats I don't care if he's
big oh I gotta get to the pond where I
don't give a [ __ ] right truly don't give
a [ __ ] um anyway we went to the factory
stores and we were like woah dude it's
got Reebok it's got Nike it's got
[ __ ] a DDoS remember when you were in
high school and the kid would call a
DDoS because he thought it was [ __ ]
German you know and it was like that's
how they said you're like dude shut the
[ __ ] up that's not how they say adidas
dude
that's how DDoS you know what you know
the right and you know it's an acronym
for all day I dream about sexton's you
know that that's what they did that no
no no that's not true
so they're out of the factory source
dude we went into the outlet factory
stores and we went into all of them and
dude I wanted to ask the clerk how did
you do it and when they say what do you
mean and I say well you successfully
created a time machine and when they say
why are you saying it I say because all
of these clothes can't exist now they
have to exist in 2004 here's the other
thing why did you only go back to 2004
if since you've created I should have
walked into that [ __ ] should have said
how's Napoleon and they say what and I
say well certainly you went back you
went back to other ages right and they
say what do you mean well you see the
thing is
everything in here you just stole from
2004 everything was [ __ ] neon green
and gray dude if you were in neon green
and gray you're in 2004 and you loved
Smash Mouth oh man
it was unbelievable every stat we dude
literally so depressing just a box
that's what the store was a box no
character to the [ __ ] store at all
fine and then just stuff thrown on the
on the on the things pink shoes like
pink and blue shoes that like nobody
would buy I can't believe factory stores
there was gas there was like Polo Ralph
Lauren
it was unbelievable I was stark raving
mad every time I walk in I go oh come on
don't have a [ __ ] factory store dude
I don't know people weren't even getting
stuff I would say like maybe it's for a
certain type of person but nobody was in
there only me
come on stark raving mad about this so
um anyway dude it was unbelievable now
is there a place called the sugar
factory that's in the Hard Rock Hotel
yes did I go yes that I can I scream yes
was it good yes then did I get ice cream
at another place because I would try and
test out all the different ice creams in
Atlantic City yes was it as good no was
it closer yes so did I go again yes
should I have gone to the Sugar Factory
because I better yes did I not know
because of laziness yes there's nothing
more [ __ ] piggy than going and getting
the worse ice-cream because it's closer
go take a few extra steps you [ __ ]
Nimrod but I wouldn't
um so I went to go get the [ __ ] I
went to the Sugar Factory and that ice
cream was bangin dude if you go to the
Hard Rock in Atlantic City that's just
bangin but if you go to the [ __ ] uh if
you go to the hardware if you go to the
oh I got that don't get food there
though I got food there and it's it it's
so good it's so gross I mean don't get I
got the salmon don't get the salmon at a
place called the sugar factory literally
someone was like oh [ __ ] which some guy
came up to me said oh [ __ ] what's she
doing here I was like what do you mean
he was like and you an actor or some
[ __ ] I was like well yeah I guess sure
yeah yeah and he was like what y'all
doing here I was like oh we're doing a
movie and he was like oh [ __ ] and I
already ordered them the ice cream and
the the lady behind the counter goes
like this here you go and gives me the
ice cream and I said cool what do I owe
you and she says you're shooting a movie
here and I said yeah and she says just
take it I don't even deserve the perks
you don't know me took a [ __ ] regular
dudes word for it just some guy with his
chick what are you doing here you
shouldn't move it yet just take it uh
sad in a way you know wow dude
Atlantic City is [ __ ] hilarious just
straight-up zero good-looking people um
I don't know so Jersey though like crazy
incredibly Jersey went to went to let me
do these ads and then I'll do it there
we go
don't talk more about how Jersey
Atlantic City is blue apron
dude I eat blue apron so much I'm gonna
turn into a blue apron okay I love it
they make really great food and you cook
it yourself and it's an experience and
it's beautiful and you eat it with your
loved ones and you go YUM a great dinner
is more than farm-fresh ingredients but
that's a great place to start with blue
aprons see
inspired and chef curated recipes you're
not just making dinner you're making
memories blue apron offers three
flexible plans the two-person plan
four-person family plan and the WW
freestyle plan Wow
choose from a variety of chef's design
recipes and get perfectly portioned
ingredients delivered right to your door
whoever helps me to discover my inner
chef and learn new recipes and
techniques now I didn't know I was I had
an inner chef but blue apron you helped
me have a hobby
thanks up to upcoming meals include
chicken chili enchilada 'z oh man I'm so
hungry now
why style glazed tilapia mmm Thai oh
well it what a typo one fire why style
glazed Thai style glazed tilapia orange
and sweet chili chicken dude anything
with chili I'm all-in Sicilian
cauliflower Stromboli is Italian to
start making delicious brag worthy meals
at home without the hassle try blue
apron check out this week's menu and get
sixty dollars off when you visit blue
apron dot-com sauce Congrats that's blue
apron dot-com / Congrats blue apron a
better way to cook my bookie look I
don't know about you guys but for me a
game is ten times more exciting when I'm
putting money on it sometimes I have a
gut feeling about a matchup and
sometimes I'm just being on my team
because they're my team I'm betting on
my team because they're my team
regardless whether you've been betting
for years or you're ready to play for
the first time my bookie is your best
bet this season if you're the kind of
guy who likes to bet a little to win a
lot try a parlay for instance if you
like a couple of the big favorites this
week parlays are perfect because they
let you bet multiple games together for
a much bigger payout so if you're gonna
bet this season do the smart thing and
go to my bookie dot AG because no one
gives you more ways to win between
football season the MLB playoffs
that's baseball and the start of the NBA
and NHL seasons
that's basketball and hockey if it's
time to get off the sidelines and get
into the action if you really want to
support your team this season don't just
sit on the sidelines get in the game
with my bookie AJ and if you join right
now my bookie will double your first
deposit use promo code Congrats to
debate the offer that's promo code
Congrats visit my bookie AG today you
play you win you get paid I went to New
Jersey
alright went to Atlantic City and it's
so it's SC Jersey we went to a place
called White House subs by the way I
went to White House subs and there's a
few White House subs and it was just
silly like I mentioned it around a local
which was annoying because I was talking
to Garrett my buddy dillahunt and he I
was like we gotta go this pickleboy subs
apparently it's really good my agent
talked about it and the guy who
overheard us is like yeah but you got to
go to the original now we know if you
know anything about me my anger is a
risin cuz it doesn't matter about the
original dude it doesn't matter I said
oh why is it better food there and he
said nah but the atmosphere and I go mmm
and then Garrett of course because he's
a real person it's like well yeah let's
go to the original alright we'll go to
the original so we drove he drove and
the whole time he was like I gotta get
gas and I was like you're fine
it's like one fourth and he was like I'm
gonna find a cast I was like you're fine
dude we got there as soon as we walked
in it was Garrett says man there's a lot
of Jersey faces in here huh and there
was everybody was talking about Frank do
you not I mean that's not what it's not
a Frank said that I heard that 14 times
while I was eating a [ __ ] sub that's
not what Frank said that's not what
carmine said heard it 14 times and and I
get there and the lady is like you know
what you want and I was like now you got
menus and she was like sure she's put
down menus and then there's a half order
and a full order at White House subs and
I was like I'm gonna get the turkey you
know how I'd do it I [ __ ] get the
turkey and the cheese if I met a some
place I got a turkey and cheese shits
because I want to rock it I don't get
the [ __ ] you know other [ __ ] I don't
mix meats too much an Italian sub is
nice let's not [ __ ] around an Italian
sub as nice as [ __ ]
but the turkey and cheese I mean I would
roll down a [ __ ] uh what do you call
it
Ralph's when I used to have a [ __ ]
car when I used to live in my apartment
I'd roll down a rough sidewalk down
there and just go get meat and cheese
dude and they'd be like yeah how's it
going regular and I'd say [ __ ] yeah meat
and cheese and I'd roll back and I'd
surprise my ex-girlfriend and I'd be
like I got me two cheese because that's
how we said it me two cheese because we
thought we were cute when we broke up
with both we both cried but me two
cheese lives on dude so now I get me two
cheese Oh
anyway I mean in the about Us section
for White House subs there's a [ __ ]
photo of the two guys who found it and
the one of the guys is chomping on a
stogie ah Jersey you want to take it
yeah the White House sub shop was opened
in October 1946 by Anthony Bastille
along with his aunt miss Celia and uncle
fritz Sacco
I said Jersey fritz
you know [ __ ] Fritz dude uncle fritz
Sacco si si si Oh Fritz is and the name
Fritz is like something that you're on
if you're going through a breakup
dude Fritz is a noise that a [ __ ]
cable like a broken cable would make for
its Fritz for threats
that's your name dude s Jersey so I'm in
1946 our parents were committed to
bringing you the best sandwich made with
the choicest meat with the choice yet
choice its choicest
choice its Jesus Christ choicest meats
anytime you say meats that seller Jersey
in Italian it will meet you one today we
their children are committed to
maintaining that same tradition of
excellence created by our parents
sincerely the Basile and Sacco currently
families and a white house gang Basile
along with aunt basilia ah sick
confusing Basile and basilia most
Italian lawyers of all time
come on down to Bastille and basilia so
we went there and I heard [ __ ] that's
not what Frank said so much so there's
the large portion in the half portion
portion and I said yeah let me get the
turkey to cheese she's like you want the
peppers and I was like oh Jersey okay
and she was like do you uh do on the
fuller the the half and I said full and
she she looked at me and she was like
full is really big and I said how big
she's a full is like that big she goes
like this she was like this okay
I mean and then half his a big and I was
like oh she's just doing it too much
cuz she thinks she thinks your boy can
unhinge his jaw yeah I mean maybe I'm a
boa constrictor you put a [ __ ]
something for me you put anything I
don't stop I stop eating when there's no
more what's this [ __ ] when people are
like ah that's enough for me
boom that's a portions dude uh how much
did you make
so I said give me the largest ism
alright so they brought the large dude
what is that Oh nah it's water so they
brought the large and is that gonna be
annoying one thing okay so they brought
the large and it was you know like if
you go to sublights like a subway if you
get the large it's two halves
dude it was four four and and it was
unbelievable and I was I own no and I
[ __ ] didn't stop eating I ate the
whole thing it's gross
so gross 1/8 the whole thing and Garrett
didn't because he's a real person is
that water what is that is that the air
here oh it is okay uh you can go turn it
off if you want it's fine
all right [ __ ] it this is real life dude
you get it and this is real life um oh
man did you guys see the [ __ ] thing
did you guys see the [ __ ] thing about
the girl falling the mom falling with
the with the on the scooter oh my god
dude we've got to watch this I put it on
twitter twitter twitter congratulations
I'm on Twitter oh man I don't know my
thing I never know my passwords it's all
good
the freaks come out at night down the
freaks come out at night
okay don't have it what are you laughing
at me what I do I can never find my
[ __ ] password from Braille and I get
so [ __ ] mad Braille I can't find my
password a Braille dude when this chick
Falls there's no sound
so I'll just [ __ ] put it on the video
podcast dude this mom who looks like my
[ __ ] friends that were twins moms
when we were [ __ ] in high school
tries to do the bird scooter and dude
it's like here's the deal man
if you have kids and they're teenagers
don't get on a bird scooter she [ __ ]
crunches her body so hard she falls so
much wobbling you know and like the
Buddha it's so funny when people fall
cuz they're like up I got it you know
they're like nah but on me though that's
what people think when they're falling
but I'm not even I mean like they're
like yeah but on me I'll figure it out
I'm not one of these [ __ ] and then
before you know it but boom dude her
whole skeleton crunches in a busy
intersection practice on the [ __ ]
sidewalk by the
don't practice next to a rare and actual
Harley also she shaped like a pair be
athletic if you uh dude she hurt herself
so bad I feel bad anyway
the bridge won't bring up because the
deserve it scale is just off the charts
with that one dude the deserve it scale
is off the [ __ ] charts with that I
mean she falls hard as [ __ ] um
wish I do these other ads yet or no
asset doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah you know
want Fargo's sure zapier you guys know
about zapier look growing a business is
hard especially when you're wasting
hours every day moving data from emails
to spreadsheets to your crm to wherever
shouldn't that kind of stuff just
happened without you lifting a finger
zabi er can help now of course I don't
lift the finger because why should i
when I have one fire he does all that
stuff for me but I know for a fact that
he uses it for automating his workflow
and keeping track of all of my money and
all of my bags zapier is the easiest way
to automate your work it connects all
your business software and handles work
for you so you can focus on the things
that matter most no more wasting your
time on tasks that you know could be
automated because that's exactly what
zapier was built to do just go to our
special link zapier dot-com / congrats
connect the apps you use most and let
zapier take it from there and uh zapier
supports more than 1500 businesses
application business applications so the
possibilities are virtually endless more
than 4.5 million people who are there
are there are more than 4.5 million
people who are saving an average of 40
hours per month by using zapier so come
on get on the you get on this app your
train right now through November try
zapier free by going to our special link
zapier
/ Congrats that's z AP ie are.com /
congrats for your first or for your free
14-day trial zapier dot-com / Congrats
butcher box you like going YUM well not
everyone has convenient access to high
quality meat high quality meats it can
be hard to find 100% grass-fed finished
beef free-range organic chicken heritage
breed pork or wild caught salmon at the
grocery store
duh and when you do find it it's
expensive Dec luckily there's butcher
box butcher box believes everyone
deserves high quality humanely sourced
meets every month butcher box ships a
curated selection of high quality meat
right to my home dude and I love it all
meat is free of antibiotics and added
hormones she knows healthy each box has
nine to eleven pounds of meat enough for
24 individual meals um hello Pak fresh
and shipped frozen and vacuum sealed so
it stays that way
butcher box it's a no-brainer it's the
best meat ship right to my door which
means one less trip to the grocers it's
the way meat should be 100% grass-fed
and finished beef all that stuff I said
earlier butcher box is the most
affordable and convenient way to get
healthy humanely raised meat right now
butcher boxes are offering new members
ground beef for life that's two pounds
of ground beef and every box for the
life of their subscription plus $20 off
the first box just go to butcher box com
/ Congrats or enter promo code Congrats
at checkout that's butcher box com /
Congrats or enter promo code Congrats at
checkout congratulations is brought to
you by cash shop the official app of the
log cabin I've been
listen dude I've been listening to
podcasts because I just download him I
listen to the [ __ ] business worst WCW
versus the WWF [ __ ] Vince McMahon was a
lunatic
dude he became a heel in the WWF he
became a character it's kind of genius
like he was using these fighters and
they would go back and forth from the
WCW to the WWF the WWF he'll visit big
man on the WWF and then we go back to
the WCW with Ted Turner owned it and he
put it on TBS and it was like a real
struggle for both of them to beat each
other out and they kept the the actors
the the wrestlers kept flip-flopping
going to the WC who would pay better you
know the contract would be up and Vince
McMahon finally got like a rap as a bad
guy and he was like [ __ ] it I'll just be
a wrestler dude and he would go out in
the ring and like argue with the
wrestlers and became a character in it
and that's how they beat out the WCW
because and then he hired the guy from
the WCW dude it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] so
[ __ ] it's unbelievable dude you got to
listen to the business worse and then
this other podcast I listen to which was
absolutely [ __ ] insane you know Keith
Morrison from [ __ ] Dateline dude it
the the the the [ __ ] thing is called
there's something about Pam oh and sorry
the thing about Pam and I swear I just
listened to it because of the guy's
voice the first three episodes were
bangin I was like wait a second and then
I realized it was maybe just the guy's
voice because Keith Morrison dude the
way he does it
first of all houses face his face it's
so long it looks like Clint Eastwood is
looking in a funhouse mirror I mean his
[ __ ] face is largely lima bean
Keith's lima bean Morrison dude that
it's so funny dude I was listening to
this first
the first episode I was listening to in
Atlantic City as I was gonna bet I got
so creeped out that I had to stop
listening to it because I got scared and
my [ __ ] yes
is it all good yes and Keith Morrison
dude just he's this guy obviously you
know from Dateline NBC Cathy singer and
Christine Filmart but the thing about
Pam you know love by the way
[ __ ] Pam that's how he's saying it I
know more about Pam I know more about
him than any of you know about Pam I
mean sings it here hold on
just listen daddy I don't know who's
better the guy from forensic vault or
the guy for real about 5:00 p.m. then he
ran errands for the next hour filled up
his tank picked up cigarettes dog food
couple of iced teas he got to Mike's
house for game night about 6:00 p.m. let
me just say that nine I'll say the head
part stopped at Arby's and drove 30 or
so more minutes to get home walking his
arrival okay it's all good
according to official records Russ said
records below had approximately nine
okay she's going through them got a
little bit dark with it at 9:30 that
night his story checked out oh but you
could tell that something wasn't sitting
right so good but you could you could
tell something wasn't sitting right with
detective dude I gotta find a good
detective I mean there was one part I
took a screenshot of it let me go get it
because it was so funny the way he said
he says Pam
[Music]
ah oh here it is Pam its episode three
fine this is the [ __ ] I do what an idiot
you know I was like I got a [ __ ] the
way he says somebody punches the air
they for us and by all the evidence he
meant really everything to do with Pam
and by all the evidence he meant
everything to do with Pam wow I love I
gotta play that it's [ __ ] three
letters the guy goes Pam oh the balls on
Keith Morrison see that's the thing dude
God he's good but of course there are
things about Pam that we didn't know
about but when we figured it out we
learned that there was more than meets
the eye in consistencies Joel decided to
look for other possible holes in the
prosecution's case like that god I want
to hang with this guy I mean imagine
just chilling with the dude just like
going to [ __ ] get some food careful
there's a yellow light um it might turn
red before you cross the line you just
be that God so [ __ ] interesting Rock
ow
the airbag burst it out
[Laughter]
you might want to watch out there's a
sharp part there's a sharp metal slab
coming out which used to be the door oh
they caught himself my favorite is when
it gets real like chilled and like
comfy with it now of course that's what
Pam would have said Pam [ __ ] I love that
guy's voice I don't know if it's him or
the other forensic file guys that's this
[ __ ] how's the forensic guy house guy go
again there was oh yeah yeah that's how
it is that was of course what was the
guy's good name is the voice right
Forensic Files for the voice the voice
voice guy I mean you know oh the behind
the scenes really Forensic Files has
always differed from other true crime TV
tick files as a film lab once an episode
is edited it's sent to the LOS
angeles-based music collective it's a
very different thing as married throw
the music really drives yeah all right
we know here's a guy here's the voice
hello yeah is so time about that time my
time in the army and then I got a radio
in 55 but here you are on the CBS
Morning Show in New York and it was you
were doing the look lad and that was let
him talk and then you'd see the engineer
there just before we start put that
diamond cutter on the disc and it would
give you the cue and I remembered the
orchestra would go first
tick tock tick tock give us a Hamilton
watch company and then music and I would
come on say the passage of time is
beyond our control but it passes
beautifully when a Hamilton marks the
hour then they would the girl was saying
was that a dream was it a dream the
passage of time you ain't [ __ ] if you
know it's tribute under Thomas was born
in Pensacola Florida on June 28 1924 I
mean I'm at like you know if you if you
don't have a tribute on YouTube you
ain't [ __ ] there's a tribute for
everyone I swear to god there's a [ __ ]
tribute for my maid that comes it'll be
like [ __ ] 24 the son of a Welsh
minister I love how to die who does this
voice from them how to communicate
probably so nervous cuz he was doing the
tribute to the [ __ ] guy who is the
[ __ ] Peter Thomas his voice is good to
project and enunciate
every night growing up Peter read
stories aloud to his family that's
[ __ ] which perfected his technique
that didn't happen
his father's philosophy words must be
visualized understood and felt before
spoken Oh imagine thinking that imagine
thinking that what a [ __ ] you'd be
succinylcholine and there were trace
amounts of succinylcholine words must be
visualized understood and felt before
spoken Pam words must be visualized
understood and felt before spoken
um but yeah it's so crazy the other lady
I [ __ ] what talking about that wait
too long but there was a lady that was
there was a lady that uh this guy got
wrongly accused of killing his wife
imagine [ __ ] you your wife gets
killed and then you get thrown in jail
and you didn't do it all right are you
kidding me dude then nothing would be
worse than that like well of course
nothing would be worse than that but
like to add insult to injury I don't
understand how these people like stay on
in the courtroom and they're just like
silent dude I'd be like hey you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I didn't do it why is he asking
that question and they'd be like
contempt contempt hostile witness
hostile uh whatever the [ __ ] I am person
on trial I'd be like dude I didn't
[ __ ] do it [ __ ] I didn't do it and
they'd be like well this is what she
this is his [ __ ] go he goes crazy see
this one I'm like no you don't
understand man there's a [ __ ] real
killer out there that's getting away
with it
I didn't do it I loved her [ __ ] cases
open dude go find it I'd being just so
quick let me tell you it right now
my wife died I'd be in jail so quick
because I would I would show so much
anger I'd be like you're not [ __ ]
doing it right dude the cops would show
up and they'd be like okay and so where
were you I was right
dude alright I wasn't here obviously
what you got killed and then now I'm
here
so what's up dude and they'd be like
whoa whoa mr. Tulio whoa did you guys
ever fight and I would be like a [ __ ]
course we did we're [ __ ] married to
each other and they'd be like dude okay
we're gonna have to take you in and I'd
be like me I didn't [ __ ] do it
get the real bad guy out there coppers
I'd be in jail immediately and they'd
make a podcast about me called the thing
about Chris the thing about Chris is he
got so mad when the police officers
showed up because he thought the cops
weren't doing their job no naturally
Chris got a little frustrated and he
swung at the cop and the cop who was
very well trained ducked and then put
Chris's arm behind his back put the
handcuffs and then Chris went to jail
for the rest of his life screamed
everyday no that's the thing dude you
could kill my wife and I would get
blamed for it no doubt there's no
[ __ ] doubt I wouldn't get blamed for
it and I'll never do that I would never
kill my wife I would never kill my wife
anyway I haven't done a podcast in
[ __ ] about a month because I have
I've had to [ __ ] try to do this [ __ ]
the movie I mean you babies up there
with me man you babies have beared with
me and you kept that you kept it you
helped me keep it real man because I had
to do episodes early I did like two in a
row once and then three and then I would
record one on Monday and then one on
Wednesday and then I finally [ __ ]
figured out that I you know I could I
can get away with not doing one until
today which is late and thank you for
thank you my babies but you know I know
you guys were waiting for it but it was
tough man getting through the [ __ ]
getting through this movie and still
doing this podcast but I still brought
it to you
because you guys are great and you
support me and also naturally bags
naturally in come naturally bags could
you you know what I was thinking about
could you have set could you if if some
if there was a killer if you knew I
think a guy I think guys could have sex
with a girl who killed somebody way
easier than a girl hood like a girl
girls Laura is talking about like this
[ __ ] where they're like oh it's so hot
serial killers are so hot like you're
[ __ ] full of [ __ ] dude you are full
of [ __ ] that's some [ __ ] that girls are
just like oh my god so happened then
like when they knew a guy would like be
a little bit creepy they'd be like L
like nah dude put your money where your
mouth is and and and and and and and
[ __ ] let the [ __ ] serial killers
Berber in your mouth you know mean don't
this is real life dude don't get out
there and start talking all crazy [ __ ]
like you want to fix up an old car
unless you're ready to go buy the
[ __ ] frame understand these chicks
will be like serial killers are so hot
and then some dude or like pop up around
her like over her shoulder and they're
like whoa you scared me that's not cool
and you're like what you said you like
serial killers all I did was [ __ ] pop
up [ __ ] that dude I'm a [ __ ] serial
killer woman in a heartbeat if she was
that girl Jodi arias or whatever the
[ __ ] isn't that that hot one are you
kidding me Jodi arias killed her husband
I mean I you know I understand it's like
[ __ ] because she it's it's horrible
but you got to get it in a little bit
doesn't mean you should stop yourself
I'm having some fun she'll still get
locked up dude
Jodi arias was slamming dude but she
killed so people are like yes
kind of hot huh doesn't make it hotter
that she's a killer no I'm not into that
[ __ ] I don't get that [ __ ] I don't let
stuff
cloud my judgment hot is hot I don't
give a [ __ ] if she like works on old
cars you know some guys like that's cool
she's got a [ __ ] business yeah it
turns me on because she's like business
you got business now you're being sexist
in a reverse way bro I got a buddy like
that that's like that's cool she's got a
real job you know a lot of these girls
in LA you know they don't have a shut up
dude
get in where you fit in dude Jodi arias
yeah hell yeah man I would date her I've
just always be on the lookout you know I
would date Jodi arias I'd also turn her
in because it's not cool to kill someone
but I would be like baby I gotta turn
you in and she'd be like what the [ __ ]
why were slamming were [ __ ] you know
we do the horizontal mambo I'd be like
baby he killed someone and I know it and
she'd be like but don't you like the way
you I [ __ ] make you Berber and I'd be
like a sweetheart he killed someone
sure like burn burn but it's over
thanks for the Berbers and that was when
chris under his relationship with Jodi
arias she killed her ex what is this
[ __ ] horse mates yes all mine yes all
mine
I got some [ __ ] what do you call it
Wells Fargo's hit me up did you buy this
did you do that did you do that
fraudulent [ __ ] I did it although thanks
for checking babies it's kind of
annoying well you don't think it's
annoying when they do that [ __ ] it's
like did you really buy this coffee
somewhere bro stop being so creepy
Wells Fargo hey did you really buy that
did you really buy a bench for your
house yeah what [ __ ] criminal is
gonna buy a bench you know we got
Chris's credit card numbers let's buy a
[ __ ] $900 bench huh he'd do them day
something if you're a criminal and you
buy a 5/9 hundred our bench have it you
know one time I started dating this
chick when I was in my high school and
the and her ex-boyfriend hated it and he
[ __ ] and he couldn't I don't know you
just couldn't [ __ ] do it he was like
he couldn't deal with it any and he
broke into my car when I was in it when
it was in the driveway when I went to
sleep and they just took a gas card and
like went and bought stuff in the gas
station so my life's hard lock any other
you know so [ __ ] funny
and whatever I stole his I stole his
girl you know I guess they're actually
steal it but she dumped him and then
liked me because [ __ ] you know I was
like well maybe you wanna hang out and
she was like sure that one I meant that
one how's that baby wanna hang out she
was like sure
[Music]
barbar baby wanna hang out sure your
buddies your ex stole my gas card I
guess that means I okay I don't know
just ended early who gives a [ __ ]
um I guess I'm over at this up dude it
was hard to come back dude it really was
hard to come back because I haven't done
a podcast in one month and it's all good
my babies but I appreciate you guys
sticking it with me and know that [ __ ]
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market and I've
got some shows coming up I told you guys
about them already but San Diego and
Foxwoods Connecticut Bethlehem
Pennsylvania Rochester New York Santa
Barbara New Buffalo Michigan in Detroit
you can download my app there support
the show by buying merch at store Chris
D'Elia calm you get this one features
two bright shirt turn around so you can
see it it's [ __ ] cool actually
so that rips and that's it subscribe to
the YouTube channel please it helps and
then you could tweet me by using the
handle congrats pod or whatever but I
don't I'm not gonna give a [ __ ] if you
do that and Wallflower writes down here
I think is a good idea but I don't give
a [ __ ] and then that's it use coming out
soon might wish to show em on
and and that's it you guys are great
okay guys thanks for listening
[Music]